[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
has this ever happened to you
what no come on
if you've ever been hurt injured or
ripped off in a fantasy football trade
then I'm here to help you mad camp your
fantasy football lawyer you'll never
have to worry about these situations
again I traded away DK Metcalf for AJ
Green and DeSean Jackson thie I got a
steal turns out I was the one who was
robbed in the end when I heard James
Connor wasn't hurt anymore I thought it
made sense to send Derrick Henry and
Mark Andrews to get him now I'm the one
that's hurting call my office is right
now and find out why I'm the best
fantasy football lawyer in the lower 48
states put the help of Matt Camp Derrick
Henry and Mark Andrews are back on my
team
it saved my marriage Thanks so Matt Kemp
I not only got DK Medcalf back but I
also got Russell Wilson and a kicker to
be named later
fantasy football is more important than
real-life laws here on your fantasy fire
drill
well from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace soon Fabulous Las Vegas is your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
mad
you take that you're good to go good
sportsmanship on this show welcome to
your fantasy fire drill i am matt camp
and in his 1977 according to this shirt
no it's week 11 in the National Football
League and we got you covered
we'll do injuries and actives sleepers
will do the jump-off will throw it back
to 1994 that lover and dr. Dre and get
you ahead on the waiver wire and plenty
of your questions will be answered on
the show and of course plenty of the
questions will be answered as soon as
I'm done I'll jump in the BR app and I
will take them for another 30 minutes
we'll get to all of it YouTube we got
you covered
hey join us here every single Sunday
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific on all
bleacher report platforms if you're in
Vegas come right here out to the sports
book I got you covered
i am matt camp and my name is not on the
injury report but a lot of important
names are so let's get to those right
now alright what do we have going on
here a lot of injuries early on will
update this as we know it's page one
it's will fuller he is out today I do
like Kenny Stills against the Baltimore
Ravens a beatable secondary there
Marquis Brown looks like he'll play we
don't have an official word if he's out
there and he should be he's got wider
Sieber to potential against that Houston
Texans secondary Devonta Freeman we know
is out you read my sleepers article on
Friday we had Brian Hill in there I
think he's got top 15 potential against
a very beatable Panthers defense Austin
Hooper will be out today I like Calvin
Ridley a little bit more than normal
good matchup there maybe he's got top 15
potential AJ Green remains out if you're
out of this right now or you need to win
this week I don't know why you're
holding on to this guy trade them to
another team that can wait for him to
come back but if you can't worry about
that Matthew Stafford is out now report
from both Adam Schefter and Ian rapport
literally just came out saying it could
be a six-week injury we're in week two
could be some time therefore Stafford Ty
Johnson clear from his concussion will
play lines backfield kind of a mess we
call the Flex at best and T Y Hilton is
out today by the way jump off on the
waiver wire Devin Funchess could be
sitting out there I picked them up today
now second page were still into the
early games we still have injuries to
discuss Adam feeling remains out now if
you haven't noticed Kyle Rudolph after I
buried them with Ochocinco a few weeks
ago is actually coming through a little
bit so he's somebody
think about it tight end today Le'Veon
Bell expected to play like to match up a
little bit more against the Redskins so
you're good to go with him
and Demaryius Thomas has been lurking
around that wide receiver three area
flex spot that's fine
he should be playing we'll see about
that in Chris Thompson is going to be
out today we'll talk more about the
Washington Redskins backfield coming up
in a bit but we have to get to the late
games and the later games and Monday and
all that stuff what do we know right now
we know chase Edmunds is out but Kenyan
Drake is the man in Arizona's backfield
more on that coming up a little bit
later on map reader very much up in the
air right now
and George kid all same thing I'm
shading towards more of they're not
gonna play I'll say a rahim most heard
is worth a look as the second back
assuming Brina won't be out now Emmanuel
Sanders reports are that he will play
you never bank on this dolmen your Flex
spot so you have a little bit more
flexibility just in case he doesn't go
now Sean Jeffery will be out against the
Patriots today not a good day for the
Eagles receivers that hasn't been in
weeks
I think Myles Sanders why miles Sanders
could get more love because Jordan
Howard is not expected to play Sanders
as a pass catcher could be a busy one
because I think the Patriots will focus
on Zach Ertz David Montgomery he's up in
the air later on we'll get into the
Bears offense you may just want to play
somebody else because he hasn't been
that consistently used anyway Brandon
cooks remains out for the Rams and then
Gerald ever it's a questionable player
we know right now we'll get into the
Rams later on that that offense is not a
real fun one to deal with we will
revisit the early game inactives as we
get updated information but now we take
your questions we'll get the plenty of
them throughout the show we'll get to
you too specifically coming up but right
now let's see what you guys have Dames
19 with Damian Williams questionable
would you start him Phillip Lindsey or
Darryl Williams he did make the trip
it's a personal tag on him it's not an
injury he made the trip I'm playing
Damian Williams he's taking over the
Chiefs backfield once again Kyle Rudolph
or OJ Howard I just talked up route off
we saw Howard came through I do like
route off a little bit more with Adam
Thielen out if there's more targets
guaranteed to come his way
next up here debo or maclaurin debo was
on my sleeper article on Friday I like
him but I liked Terry McClure and more I
think he bounces back after help bad
weeks against the bad jet
defense start three bail Tevin Coleman
Macker Hill I think we just sit down
Hill as much as I talked them up I trust
those other three names a little bit
more a half point PPR Lindsay bored or
blocked are one I'll just go with
Lindsay there I do not trust balázs at
all cuz frankly he's just not very good
next Darrin fells are fans I'm gonna go
with Fant I know there's a little bit of
a groundswell here he's getting a bigger
role I think he's worth a look
especially what fells your other options
so now we do this we take plenty of your
questions but if someone's gonna get up
early enough to show up here in Vegas
and ask me a question I'm gonna go out
and help them we are out in the sports
book right now welcome in a couple of
Bills fans guys your name's Nolan Nolan
Brad Brad alright what's your question
Matt yeah that's me Tyler Boyd in my
lineup he's projected for one more point
on Yahoo then Calvin Ridley he's still
like Calvin Ridley well the good thing
is this is in Yahoo it's bleacher report
and that's where I will tell you to use
Calvin Ridley today good luck to you go
bills go Bills Bills alright guys thank
you very much we got you good luck to
the bills good luck to Calvin Ridley
it's time for your matte moment though
didn't see you there hey you remember
September what time that was
I told you that juju Smith Shuster was a
first-round pick hi I'm Matt Kemp
corporate she'll do anything for your
money we're gonna take you back to
September and all of my wacky
predictions with this five CD set that's
right it's Matt camps fantasy football
gold you'll get hits like Austin Eckler
running back one the Browns championship
hopes
Josh Rosen's redemption in Miami
you'll also get these favorites Jameis
Winston will protect the ball this year
Matt Negi football genius Marcus Mariota
is a starting quarterback now and get
these bonuses with these fantastic cuts
no you shouldn't draft Russell Wilson
before Carson Wentz and Antonio Brown
will be just fine
Kanye West isn't crazy it's all here on
Matt camp's fantasy football goal I mean
I don't get 3,000 things wrong we got
some things right didn't we well here's
what we do now this is about adjusting
expectations not about dropping players
out right but maybe you drafted somebody
way up here and now they're down here
and down here or moving things back up
and down what I want to do is review
some big-name players situations teams
that the narrative has changed and not
for the good for the bad and we'll start
with a team that went to the Super Bowl
last year and it feels like they've had
a hangover ever since then it's the
ramps I told you to trade Todd Gurley
like three weeks ago hopefully you did
if you didn't you're stuck with a guy
who's not catching passes needs to score
a touchdown and it's not getting those
chances because the Rams aren't very
good and a big reason why might be Jared
Goff they played Blake bortles okay they
said it was the plan McVeigh he seems to
be going through through some stuff
right now the confidence in the Rams
that you may have had last year and into
this year is just not there right now
next up here and I know all of you know
about this but Oh what is going on with
David Johnson this is why you try to
rush a guy through injuries bad things
happen the best two games by a Cardinals
running back this season have not come
from that guy that came from chase
Edmunds and came from Kenyan Drake on
Thursday night a couple weeks ago
Kenyans rakes the head of this guy David
Johnson is a flex option at best and I
don't even feel good saying that don't
get fooled by name-value he's not
playing at that level now speaking of
last year the Chicago Bears offense
looked a lot better something you wanted
to invest in we don't feel that way
right now
speaking of coaches don't feel very good
Matt
deal with mr. Biscay we'll try Biscay
even be starting on Thanksgiving
I don't feel real good about that and
David Montgomery might not even play I
like David Montgomery but there hasn't
been consistent chances and on an
offense that's average at best it's not
like they're even good chances so think
about that when you're making your
lineup decisions that's the bad and if
you need help while I have you covered
right now because it is time for my week
eleven sleepers
[Music]
the waiver wire this season has not
given us enough impact players as bad as
I can remember now coming up later on
we'll give you the jump on some players
you may want to grab but we're talking
week to week we're talking who can i
grab play this week and not worry about
what they do next week we're just
talking about this week quarterback is
where we start quarterback his position
you can stream we gave you Daniel Jones
last week he was QB to I'm going back to
Derek Carr who by the way he's played
some pretty good football over the last
month Gruden's got this team playing
well we can't wait for them to come to
Vegas come maybe as a winner and cars
got the bangles the opposite of a winner
sorry Chad this is what I will tell you
it's a very beatable defense and car is
playing well Tyrell Williams
Renfro Waller it's pretty good right now
their cars got top ten potential for
week 11 now we move on here to the wide
receiver position and debo Samuel now I
know Sanders Manuel Sanders looks like
he'll play but Kittel banged up reader
banged up and people Samuel was great
and he's got the Cardinals good matchup
he can do some damage
working at wide receiver today I want to
invest in good offenses he's in a really
good one because Kyle Shanahan cares
about our fantasy team one more and we
always have to dig deep at the tight end
position I'm gonna tell you to take a
look at Ryan Griffin everybody was on
Chris Hearn and I'm around he got hurt
now he's gone again Ryan Griffin was
connected with Sam Darnell's he's got
the Redskins tonight that's not a bad
matchup at all so if you're really
hurting as you sit here watching me this
morning and say maybe I could get a
little bit of a boost that tight end I
don't like what I have take a look at
Ryan Griffin because he was actually
getting some things done so there you go
sleepers article out and full every
single Friday Kyle Allen's on there this
week few other names check that out
that's what we feature but now more of
your questions here because we are here
to help you on your fantasy fire drill
what do we have here first let's see
flex one PPR mckissick Freeman our
stills I'll go it stills I'll put my
money where my mouth is without will
fuller I think he's got a shot against
that Ravens secondary Robert woods our
Hollywood Brown I'm gonna go Hollywood
Brown out there against the Texas today
that's we said the Rams not looking so
good next up here John Brad Emmanuel
Sanders for Gallup well you have to wait
on Sanders we don't know about that I
like Gallup Browns the safe play for you
big I just play it safe with John Brown
David Montgomery Mark Andrews if
Montgomery was healthy I'd be telling to
start mark Andrews so I will stick with
him as one of those few tight ends you
can trust every single week next up
Hollywood Brown Ridley Kirk or Hill
I like the upside of riddling today
against the Carolina Panthers especially
we lost the Hooper out there more
targets coming his way we'll go with
Calvin Ridley nice let me back off
waivers if you're sitting here on a
Sunday morning take a look at Brian Hill
who's probably gone Raheem mosters for
San Francisco I think it's another name
to consider and we'll get some more
running backs you can grab coming up in
a little bit but now to the wall for a
question amen it's Kendrick what is
going on with the Redskins backfield
Kendrick keeping it short and sweet what
is going out with that backfield Darius
guys coming back the Redskins we told
you weeks ago were an evaluation mode so
why wouldn't you take an extended look
at darius guys
well the Redskins do that you know how
that management goes who knows I don't
think him nor Peterson is it anything
more than a flex but the Redskins would
be very smart to feature him down the
stretch one problem they stink so how
much confidence can you really have that
is a fair question but I don't think for
Kendrick or anybody else that situation
is gonna really feel that great unless
they absolutely go with guys we'll see
if that is indeed the case thank you for
the question all right so there's no
London game stop watch with me
well shake it Maddie hey that's Matt
Ryan he plays for the Falcons I'm Matt
Sweeney whack you with a wicked host
those Bojan balls
I Nicky Nick out to jump off is that a
thing yet is a thing and that's what
we're doing right now it's time for the
jump the jump ball yeah we did that so
it's not 1970 it's 1993 dr. Dre add
lover yeah yo MTV raps that's our
shout-out to you what I want you to do
is look at your record are you 8 and 2
or 7 and 3 right now and feeling good
you're on top of the standings you're
you're on your way to the fantasy
playoffs you may want to get head up
ahead on the waiver wire you might have
a spot available I want to look at four
running backs four running backs who
could pay dividends if their number is
called due to injury let's start to look
at those right now we're looking at
situations where they could step into a
big role and that includes Gus Edwards
Gus Edwards when I got you the fantasy
playoffs last year he's playing behind
Mark Ingram right now I hope marketing
room stays healthy and ready to go and
takes Baltimore into January but if he
does go down for some reason here's the
guy that steps up for Baltimore on one
of the best rushing offenses in football
I'd want a piece of that if you have
room take a look at Gus Edwards because
if Larkin here goes down you can be took
that top 15 running back next name up
here in a situation that I also love
Alexander Madison he's the number two
back behind Dalvin cook in Minnesota
Dalvin cook having one of the best
fantasy seasons of any player right now
in a big role but Madison when we see
them sprinkled in it looks very good
let's say hopefully he doesn't happen of
course cookware to go down Madison
another player who could step into it a
big role on a good team and be a top 15
running back now we'll drop down a
little bit here with these next two I'm
not quite as confident but still once
again good situation for Tony Pollard
he's barely playing behind Zico
that's a whole different story but Zeke
were to go down Sony's hollard steps in
on a good offense on a contending team
where he would play a very important
role not quite as important as years
past in Dallas because their passing
game is pretty good shout out to dak and
Michael Gallup and Cooper but Pilar
would be looking at 15 touches a game if
Zeke were to go down stash them away
it's a good spot and then one more going
a little bit further down he's the
former first-round pick Chris Carson's
getting all the love there in Seattle as
he should be
but that offense is good Chris Carson's
a big part of it another contending team
Rashad Penny Rashad Penny's not doing
much right now and I don't expect them
to do anything unless Chris Carson were
to be out of the mix so those are four
names that if you're really high up in
the standings you're saying there's
nobody on the waiver wire just in case
something happens you are ahead of
everyone else in your league and you
stash them away by the way if you're
like four and six or five and five right
now these are not the names through you
you got other things to worry about but
now I worry about you I learn about you
on YouTube let's get to your questions
right now more questions coming my way
Conor sis and I start Breezer Merle
holds this week you have a trade to make
Conor trade whoever brings back more
I'll always try to play Patrick mahomes
go Evans or Godwin well just another one
I'm gonna say Mike Evans but it's a flip
flop every week let's hope Jameis
Winston gets both guys involved next
Le'Veon or Brian Hill I like both this
week but I like Bell more I think he
plays a much more important role for the
Jets against the Redskins he could have
his busiest game to date as a New York
jet against the Redskins later on
mahomes are Brady my first season of
fantasy need help soccer boy you got a
good spot there maybe you trade one of
them I'll always tell everyone to play
patch home to catch with mahomes
questions a new record Olson or Mark
Andrews I like Mark aids against the
Texas good matchup their roll with him
another spot where you have two players
you could trade one of them cousins or
Kyler
Kirk Cousins playing real solid football
just talking to Kelly about this and I
think I'm with her he's been getting the
job done
now do we go to the wall for a celebrity
question
I have the benefit of having all Lamar
Jackson on my team right he's probably
the reason why my team is having any
type of success I'm wondering if I could
make my team better by trading them how
many players should I trade him for and
which players mr. Fontaine with a very
good question that he said he has Lamar
Jackson if he has another starting
caliber quarterback we just got a couple
of those right Brees mahomes or brady
mahomes if you have two guys that what
absolutely be in starting lineups trade
one of them bring yourself back a
running back and receiver get multiple
starting caliber players because you
only need one now if he only has Lamar
Jackson I'm not gonna get cute I would
just stick with that but if you have two
quarterbacks that could be in starting
lineups move one of them you'll help
yourself out elsewhere and reap the
benefits that's what we do
little trade stuff from earlier but now
we revisit the ins and outs the inactive
updated information for our early games
will fuller as we know out as I said I
like Kenny Stills and I like Marquis
Brown who is in today Hollywood taking
on that Texan secondary a very beatable
matchup they're Devonta Freeman out
Brian Hills got top 15 potential Hooper
out I like Calvin Ridley a little bit
more as well against that Panther
defense AJ Green remains out it's
basically Boyd or bust there with Jill
Mixon Matthew Stafford could be multiple
weeks for that injury Jeff Driskel still
starting Ty Johnson clear from his
concussion he will play he's a flex
option see why Hilton out pascal's okay
I will tell you to take a look at Devin
Funchess if he's on your waiver wire not
back yet we'll be back soon now more of
our early game inactives that we know
about Adam feeling this out I do think
there's a boost there for Kyle Rudolph
it has happened lady on bail is in today
I think he's got a good week for a
top-ten game with confidence because we
haven't said that a lot Demaryius Thomas
is in as well he's a flex at best but
he's been getting it done and Chris
Thompson is out it's guys and Adrian
Peterson how will that shake out I think
that something we'll have to keep an eye
on for the next couple of weeks now late
game inactives what we know so far some
of the stuffs locked in chase Edmunds is
out I favor Kenyan Drake over David
Johnson map-reading we will see about I
told you about Raheem ulster if you're
real stuck he's the named
sitter torch Kittel on the doubtful side
I don't expect to see him I wouldn't
Bank on having him Emmanuel Sanders
looks like he'll play far from the lock
but sounds better than did a couple of
days ago now Sean Jeffery out for the
Patriots and the Eagles I think they're
gonna focus the Patriot defense on
Earth's take a look at miles Sanders why
Jordan Howard not expected to play today
Sanders could be their top receiver
believe it or not David Montgomery is
also a game time decision I just think
you sit him the Bears haven't been that
good he hasn't been great they don't
want to go with him the offense isn't
great we talked about earlier so don't
even risk that Brandon cooks is out
you'd like to play Robert woods and
Cooper Cup with confidence hopefully
that's there and Gerald Everett we'll
see about that
so there's your ins and outs and
inactives let's get as many questions in
as we can to finish this up it's time
for the speed round
[Music]
we got to a ton on the show today coach
we're moving fast enough moving fast and
I got big news for you baby
Little Women Greta Gerwig Christmas Day
Peter scanning speed round that's a new
one all right there we go we got Andrew
sir Waller there's a trade to make there
I'm gonna play Waller against the
Bengals defense I like that matchup
champ tonight few lines wide receivers
gala day and Jones who do I start I'll
always go with a more talented player
we're gonna play Kenney gala day this
week next up John Brown or Malcolm
Marquis Brown excuse me I always feel
safer about John Brown I'd say
Hollywood's got more upside if you think
you're an underdog in your match up next
Brooklyn flex playing a quarter point
PPR Bell versus Washington DJ Moore
versus Atlanta a quarter point can I
hurt more MORE I like Le'Veon Bell for a
busy day against the Redskins
next up two good quarterbacks and bad
matchup Tyler Wentz Jason was just up
here the coach had this exact question
I will go calimary he did it against the
Niners a couple of Thursday's ago we'll
go back to him next should I drop
latavius Murray for Carlos Hyde I don't
think you have to you might get more
guaranteed touches so sure if you want
to take a shot I just don't think it's a
big difference between the two players
next up Corliss up DJ tark Stefon Diggs
I like playing gigs without feelin and
I'll go with shark will sit Sutton you
got to sit somebody good there I hate to
say it will play the quarterbacks there
and sit Sutton of that goo Prescott or
Ryan decks playing some real good
football right now I'll continue to roll
with him back Prescott your guide
another trade to make their play collar
against tough matchup where stream Derek
Carr Kyle Allen I am on Derek Carr I
also like Kyle out I like them both more
than Murray we're gonna play Derek Carr
against the Cincinnati Bengals
Raiders are Ravens defense I like a bowl
today but I like the Raiders more
because of that bangles matchup you fire
up the Raiders defense try drop Cristian
Kirk the stash T why mother wide
receivers are feeling Robinson and Julio
I don't know if I want to jump into that
question because that's kind of tough
wise CY help now this no no no that's a
joke
okay it's not right um if you can get
Hilton okay I don't think I want to drop
Kristin Kreuk to do so next who should i
stash through the future may feel once
or poles I'm gonna fall back on once I
think they'll be okay
hopefully help is working in the Eagles
favor moving forward tough spot to buy
should I pick up and play most or
pelagic McKissack I'm gonna go with the
best often said I'll tell you to play a
rahim most for the Niners of breathe'
likely out who do I start RB to four
point PPR Joe mix and James White
Singletary White's probably the safest
so I might just go there
Nixon's keep it close enough to get the
volume you got to go with what you think
is upside now I got to a lot of
questions but I'm getting two more I'll
be in the app for the next thirty
minutes and I'll get as many questions
as I can covered there hey big bore
comes out of Wednesday sleepers on
Friday and I also do a mail back there
but I'm here for you
in Las Vegas at the sports book every
single Sunday morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30
Pacific watch on all bleacher report
platforms and good luck to you in week
11 i'm matt camp this has been your
fantasy fire drill
[Music]